All right.
If you said positive 2 for this exponent great work. When I multiply by a
positive power of 10, I move the decimal two places right. For this next one I
notice that my decimal point is here. I need to make it go to the left side of
6. I know that my exponent needs to be negative since I'm moving my decimal
left. If I go one spot The decimal would be here, but I need two more zeros. So,
I'm going to go one, two, and the decimal will end up here. Remember, I add
zeroes as place holders whenever I move the decimal. I move the decimal three
places to the left, so my exponent is negative 3. Okay, so, for this one, my
decimal starts here. I don't have anything after the decimal. And I notice that
I need to move it to the left. So I'm going to go one, two, three, four. My
decimal moved four spots to the left. So I have to have an exponent of negative
4. And this case I want my decimal point to end up to the right of 6 and one
more place, here. So I'm going to move it, one, two, And then I have to add 1
more spot, where a zero would be as a place holder. So I moved it one, two,
three, four spots. So positive 4 would be this exponent. Remember, positive
exponents move our decimal place to the right. Negative exponents move the
decimal place to the left.